in the direction of Kherson today at 5
o’clock in the morning Moscow time,
the transfer of units of
Russian troops to the left bank of the Dnieper river was completed
not a single piece of military equipment and
weapons was left on the right bank
all Russian military personnel
crossed to the left bank of the Dnieper river
the military units of the Russian
armed forces occupied the unit in advance
defensive lines prepared in terms of engineering and positions of
loss of personnel armament of
military equipment and materiel of the
Russian group of troops not allowed to
all civilians who wished
to leave the right-bank part of the Kherson
region assistance was provided in the evacuation of
two spans of the Antonovsky bridge
the withdrawal of Russian troops to the
left bank of the Dnieper was successfully completed as
announced to the Ministry of Defense of the
Russian Federation
[music]
today is a historic day, we will turn
our Ukraine back to Kherson, I will
turn on the turnover for pizza to the place, the
pre-trial detention center is overstated for everyone and under  chin
comes to him special thigh make already
fit